مع دخول القتال في السودان
أسبوعه السادس، أجبر مئات
الآلاف من الأشخاص على الفرار من منازلهم
وفقًا لتقرير جديد صادر عن
المنظمة الدولية للهجرة التابعة للأمم المتحدة، ونزح أكثر من
مليون شخص في
السودان وفر أكثر من 300 ألف إلى
الدول المجاورة 80.000 منهم إلى
تشاد أو مراسل سي إن إن لاري مادوا
يقدم لنا الليلة تقريرًا
ستشاهده فقط على شبكة سي إن إن،
الأطفال يبكون باستمرار، والكبار يبدون
متعبين من الحرب، وجوه الطلاء هنا هي
تذكير بالفظائع التي قادتهم
خارج السودان في مخيم اللاجئين هذا عبر
الحدود في تشاد، يطارد الحزن
الجميع تقريبًا، حيث اشتد القتال في
منطقة دارفور الغربية بالسودان، وكان عليهم
الفرار أو المخاطرة بالقتل.
غادرت هابرا عبد الله فجأة لدرجة أن ابنها
ضاع في الفوضى، ولا
يزال أخي عائدًا.  هناك سمعت
أنه أصيب وأجبرت على القدوم إلى
تشاد بحثًا عن الأمان، هل ستعود إلى
السودان
لا لا، السبب الوحيد الذي يجعلني أعود هو
إحضار طفلي وأخي إلى هنا، لقد كان هناك
الكثير من انعدام الأمن لفترة
طويلة
لأن  من عقود من الصراع في السودان، كان
العديد من هؤلاء اللاجئين قد
نزحوا داخليًا عدة مرات.
ماسترا تبلغ من العمر 22 عامًا ولكنها لم تعرف
منزلًا دائمًا طوال معظم حياتها.
أنا قلق بشأن جميع الأشخاص الذين تركناهم
خلفنا وهم
يقتلون والدتي التي  لم أتمكن من عبور
الحدود،
وأظل أسأل نفسي كيف يمكنني أن أجعلها
تتحدث، لاحظت أن معظمهم من النساء
والأطفال هنا، أين الرجال من
السودان،
أخبرنا الرجال أن نأخذ الأطفال
ونعبر الحدود حتى يتمكنوا من البقاء في الخلف
للدفاع عن أنفسهم  وممتلكاتنا إذا
لزم الأمر،
تقول المفوضية السامية للأمم المتحدة لشؤون اللاجئين إن ما يقرب من 90
بالمائة من الوافدين الجدد المسؤولين من
السودان هم من النساء والأطفال، والعديد منهم مصابون
بصدمات نفسية لدرجة أنهم سيحتاجون إلى الكثير من
الدعم للشفاء. كنا نتوقع مقابلة
اللاجئين عند وصولهم إلى الحدود
بلدة كفرون على الجانب الآخر من السودان،
ولكن قبل وصولنا مباشرة، أصيبت
بصاروخ، وهذا هو السبب وراء
نقل اللاجئين بعيدًا عن البلدات الحدودية إلى أماكن
مثل هذه في غاغا.
سافرت سي إن إن مع مديرة الوكالة الأمريكية
سامانثا باور إلى شرق تشاد، والولايات المتحدة
تقدم المزيد  أكثر من 100 مليون دولار
لدعم أكثر من مليون شخص
نزحوا بسبب الحرب في جميع أنحاء السودان وفي
البلدان المجاورة، التقينا بامرأة
تم اقتلاع عينها بشكل أساسي عندما
هاجمها شخص ما وهي
تبحث عن رعاية طبية هنا في تشاد،
العنف المروع الذي أدى إلى ذلك
العديد من هؤلاء الأشخاص لديهم أيضًا ذكريات عن
أعمال عنف مروعة سابقة، إنها
لحظة دائرة كاملة بالنسبة لها، كانت في دردشة عام
2004 تكتب في مجلة نيويوركر عن
المدنيين السودانيين الفارين من جانجا
مع الميليشيات في دارفور، تتحدث معهم
وتشعر وكأنك في زمن  الاعوجاج
لأنهم يصفون مجيئ جانويت
بسكاكينهم ومناجلهم
ويقتلون الأشخاص الذين يغتصبون النساء، هل من
السريالي أن تكون هنا وتسمع هذه
القصص عندما سمعتها قبل 20 عامًا
كمراسل
يشعر بأنه محظوظ هذه المرة على الأقل لأنه
يعمل في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية  إلى
الوكالة الإنسانية التنموية الكبيرة، على الأقل هناك
شيء يمكنني القيام به ولكن في الأساس
لا يوجد بديل
عن معالجة الأسباب الجذرية
لهذين الجنرالين المتحاربين لوضع
سيطرتهما على السلطة جانبًا ووضع
مصالح هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
يفرون أحيانًا للمرة الخامسة  تشاد،
إحدى
أفقر دول العالم، كان بها حوالي 400000
لاجئ سوداني قبل هذه
الموجة الأخيرة، ونحن بحاجة إلى العمل بشكل جماعي
مع جميع الجهات الفاعلة لدعم
الحكومة المسؤولة لضمان
تعبئة الموارد
لمعالجة المشكلة.  الاحتياجات العاجلة للاجئين،
هؤلاء هم الضحايا الأبرياء
للصراع المميت على السلطة في السودان، أنقذوا
الكاميرا الفقراء والأكثر ضعفاً الذين
ليس لديهم مكان يذهبون إليه، مجرد فصل آخر
في حياة مليئة بالمصاعب.
أندرسون، سرعان ما امتد الصراع في السودان
إلى صراع  أزمة اللاجئين الإقليمية،
هذه الإحصائيات اللاحقة الصادرة عن
الأمم المتحدة مهمة، فهناك 1.3 مليون شخص
نزحوا معظمهم في السودان ولكن أكثر من
300000 عبروا إلى
البلدان المجاورة مثل مصر وتشاد،
واللاجئون الذين التقيت بهم في الكنيسة الشرقية لا
يعيشون في ظروف مريحة، الحرارة
وحدها هي أكثر
يعيشون في هذا المزيج من
الهياكل في الصحراء، بدرجة حرارة تزيد عن 110 درجة فهرنهايت، لكنهم ما زالوا
يفضلون أن يكون الجو أكثر أمانًا لهم من
دارفور حيث أتوا، وقد
نزح الكثير منهم أحيانًا ما يصل
إلى خمس مرات ولا يهتمون  أي
من الحربين بشكل عام السودان يفوز
بهذا إنهم يريدون السلام فقط يريدون
نفس الأشياء أنت وأنا نريد فرصة
لحياة كريمة وسوف يعودون
لمن يستطيع أن يسلم ذلك لهم
أندرسون لاري مادوا تقرير شكرا لك